everybody welcome to the live coding
with Jesse today we're gonna switch
things up a little bit from what we've
been doing this week and we're gonna get
back and do some UI work we'll work a
little bit with CSS and with the
material UI components so I noticed in
yesterday's stream when we were bringing
in some of the data we tried to look at
the pages and some of the data was
hidden because we were pulling in the
styles for another page so it occurred
to me after the stream that of course
we're pulling in those Styles right
because we copied and pasted everything
from the other page into that new
component so we're still importing those
same styles so I thought you know the
first thing that we ought to do today is
go through and maybe strip out the more
specific styles and have maybe one style
sheet that has some of the more you know
basic things that would be Universal you
know across all the pages and then I'll
test out some of those pages that didn't
look right yesterday see if they look
all right and we can always make is we
can make adjustments for specific cases
you know as we see them but so far most
of the page have been looking alright so
I don't think we'll need to adjust too
much I think it's I don't have a live
setup yet so let me get this ready
alright hey everybody
okay
all right so I guess we'll get started
everything looks good with the stream
whatever changes I have made in the OBS
settings at the beginning of the week I
think that really did the trick we've
had no trouble at all with the stream
quality so that's that's good
there was a while there or I just wasn't
sure what it was gonna be like and it's
Sneaky's birthday today
happy birthday so Nikki or rook from the
live chat is it's actually here for the
stream for that's really cool that
you're watching on your birthday so
happy birthday again all right now y'all
can see my screen so I was doing some
data migration so that's why I'm here in
our migrate jas file I'm gonna switch
over though and show you let's see I
make it a bit bigger for you all let's
shrink this down and let's bring up the
N grog server because in when we're
doing things like this I think and rock
is really helpful because I'll probably
be looking at my dev tools and so if you
can look you know on your screen as well
it's a lot nicer alright so I am going
to paste this in
all right so now that links that link is
available and you all can see the same
site that I'm looking at that I'm
running locally all right now this is
our page J s component which we made and
it's supposed to be just a component
that can be used for a variety of
content types
so that's all the problem for us of you
know we were making new components for
every content type and we're starting to
get a lot of types and a lot of
components so this will save us a lot of
time and clean things up it works but
you can see here that we are bringing in
the news CSS so news dot CSS so let's
let's try to create a new CSS page now
the reason we're not using something
more like styled components or anything
is because we're bringing in a large
chunk of HTML from our database for now
that's the way we have to do it
eventually we can do something different
with it but right now there's not enough
time to get all that data reformatted so
we're just bringing in the HTML as is
because of that we need to use style
sheets right I can't go in and add a
class to something in here because the
data is coming from here right I don't
really know what's gonna be there you
know to add a class to so we're just
going to do our best to set up styles
that are most likely to look good over a
variety of types and then hopefully we
can test enough pages to catch most of
the cases this is a very large site
thousands of pages so as long as we
cover the pages that are most frequently
viewed and I'll probably check the
analytics here soon not during the
stream but I mean you know within the
next week or so just to double-check
make sure that the pages that get
visited the most or where we we spend
the most
looks like Nikki's getting errors in the
console what it's your birthday you
shouldn't get errors on it for your
birthday
let's check this out and see see if I'm
getting any errors as well I'm getting
some kind of errors let me refresh this
and see I'm getting all right so here's
what I'm getting in terms of errors I
mean I can still see everything oh here
we are
mm-hmm we have have this one that
unexpected whoops
you know what I've seen errors like that
before I can't remember what they were
though oh you know it was it just that
page let me go back this axis you know
it's not Texas vanishing avoiding a
connection yeah
all right that's odd it must be there
must be something going on with what
we're bringing in here on this page
because it's not happening
you know in this page well we'll see
we'll give it a minute maybe we'll get
it but it mm-hmm
yeah we are getting it here on this page
as well so I'm not really sure what the
problem is obviously it's not affecting
you know the view of things and we'll
just we'll keep an eye on that
all right what was I gonna totally have
just lost what I was gonna do now I I
think I was gonna make a new CSS file I
think that's what I was talking about
all right so let's see our static folder
so within our static folder let's make a
new file and we'll name it pick page CSS
so if you notice the pattern we're
naming our fight our CSS files the same
name as the component that they go with
and we're doing the same thing with our
queries we name our queries our graph QL
queries the same name as the component
that they go with so it can be a bit
confusing when we have pages here like a
page a s and a page a s so there are
downsides to doing it like that but also
there's no confusion about which things
go together all right so since we have
this component here with nothing in it
we need to bring some things in so I'm
going to pull in now let me compare here
the Faculty CSS and the new CSS
hmm
I think I'm going to bring in the
faculty CSS because it does not have one
problematic piece which is the
display:none for their route component
so let's try that out first and we'll
see how it looks
weird my they get closed out my new file
here there we are
alright I'm going to save that and then
in our page das component
let's bring in instead of news spring in
our page dot CSS file okay so now that
saves let's check it out and refresh all
right so for this particular page
everything looks fine I'd like to go
back to that page that was giving us the
issues and you know what I'm gonna make
this bigger I'm gonna make this 150 it
should be a little easier to see
150% of what I set the screen to I have
this set to 320 pixels because as far as
I know that is the minimum screen width
in pixels that that's available right
now for a mobile device so we don't have
to worry about anything below that which
is good because the the menu here just
barely fits we may have to make the menu
a little bit more narrow but any less
than that you wouldn't really be able to
shock the menu all right so let me think
about all right if I hit back we'll find
it because I don't remember exactly what
with the page was
our mission
[Music]
okay just you know kind of quickly
glancing this is looking pretty good I
don't see okay you know there's nothing
really standing out is this looks awful
of course if there happens to be some
data that's completely missing here you
know because it's hidden or something I
won't really know about that let's go
back hopefully we have something it's
just the film studies minor alright that
wasn't the one that didn't work
hurry come on alright so I can't
remember which one didn't work if
anybody remembers which one didn't work
let me know in the live chat otherwise
I'm gonna try to refresh my memory by
looking at our post types
her shirt says academics there was a
page in academics that didn't work all
right let me check what content we have
in academics right now to see if I can
remember what it was
I don't remember what it was I don't
know why I really should have tried
harder to remember that
good have I don't know who we even have
a academics page in our history here no
okay
the harsh it says it was academics
English okay let's try that then
let me see
actually no I don't have any content for
English under academics if it was
English maybe it was under something
else under departments maybe - I have a
departments for English
all right let's see we have for the
English department I don't think it was
that the I don't remember ever trying to
look at that mm-hmm archers let's view
recording a previous dream yeah I know I
can do that I just don't
alright let's let's do some inception
style stuff here let's view the previous
stream alright so hopefully we don't
cause anything crazy to happen let me
try to see a messed up screen there it
is
Austria that's what I have academics
Austria courses offered alright that was
way easier than I thought it would be
oops
I moved the wrong thing alright let's
check that out there we are
alright still can't see that so you have
some work to do why is it still like
that
check out our main content and root this
is what used to be display:none it's not
displayed on anymore
so where is a content
this is the one all right okay this is
one that one of the tags is a title tag
which is crazy
let's see so we'll definitely need to
make sure we change title tags that that
should probably be just kind of a
universal thing if a title tag comes
through the data we definitely just
switch it I think we're pretty safe to
switch titles two h2s across the board
let's see
there is no subtitle although we
probably should switch subtitle to I
don't know we'll have to see what works
maybe an h4 or something but see if it
displays anything at all right now
okay it actually does display so we
don't really need to change that I'm
okay with that being subtitle for now
because even that that size is okay with
me all right so now let's check out
these tabs oh we have a title within the
tabs all right so it's gonna be a little
tricky I don't think we can just go with
h2s all the time all right so maybe we
can get yeah so its titles are
display:none by default which is that
makes sense
hmm I definitely don't want to leave it
as title so here's what we do we can
switch it up and hmm I'd really hate to
have a bunch of h2s but maybe we might
have to do that for now like this is not
going to be the final version of this
markup for now maybe we we have all h2s
and then if you have h2s that are inside
tabs they'll be a little bit smaller
font size
so that's not ideal ideal but so I mean
ideally you have a hierarchy to your
structure right so changing the size is
not really a big deal but having that
many headings on your page and saying
they're all of equal weight is I mean
it's just not true right the main title
should be an h1 or potentially an h2 and
then anything below that can't be at
that same level all right so from you
know and
CEO point of view we're trying to tell
them what the most important thing is
and I'm not sure if it has an impact on
screen readers or not but I suppose it
couldn't hurt to be more explicit with
you know this is the main heading these
are the subheadings so for now we'll do
the h2s we'll switch everything h2s but
it's not gonna be like that forever
it'll probably end up staying like that
when we launch but eventually we're
gonna change it okay so see we have
title all right - this whole thing
you're just titles titles and then write
title okay so I think it might not be a
bad idea to bring this up here and see
what they what all this markup was
supposed to look like originally well
Austria is gonna need to have its own
post site there are a lot of Austria
pages see academics but I think it's
this page
- this one
hmm that's interesting
maybe the content we're dealing with
isn't even actually linked anymore uh
sure courses offered where did we pull
that all right well in any case we're
gonna display this as you know just one
list let's see all right let's do that
lets go to our component now we've done
something similar in another component
so let's find that to find that one it
wasn't news let's check our news
component now it wasn't news all right
let's check out directories Department
no I know that I did something faculty
there we are okay so here's what we did
so I know Harshit was talking about
pulling data and changing the changing
the data like as we pull it in with a
regular expression that's one way to do
it but I've already pulled it in and
I've put in a lot of data so there's no
way I'm pulling in all that data again
so another way to do this you know after
the fact since we already have this data
is to do something like this so here I
just kind of you know created this to
grab the data so that same data that we
would normally input here I just made a
constant here that takes that data and
replaces details with div class details
and then puts an ending div tag where
the ending details tag was and then down
here we simply
put content so it's it's pretty simple
it's easy to tell when you look at the
component what's happening so it's not a
it's not a bad solution and this is
something that I suppose could be you
know pulled out into its own kind of
utility component if there were enough
things like this going on that we could
reuse for now we don't really have that
going on but let's take this if we see
other things like a details component
you know coming in that we want to
change you know we could definitely
reuse this at some point we might want
to have just you know all content
running through something like this but
we don't really know what we need until
we go through more of this content
alright so let's go back to our pages
dot j/s component and let's put some of
this in here actually let me make sure
where was this faculty okay
it's so inside of our return is that we
had it yeah goodness was in our render
function I believe it was in our render
function I can double check I suppose
alright here we are
I don't know I must have accidentally
copied but I didn't want to copy okay
oops I have too many pages open let's
get rid of I'll say let's get rid of
what we don't need there we are
faculty okay so yes within our render
function and not the return function
there we are and blocks what's not a pad
about okay all right so let's change
this up and so we have title now we're
going to change this well
let's change the title and then here
well we'll give it a class of title just
so that we can remember like when we're
inspecting that this used to be a title
tag it should help us you know if we
have to go into dev tools and try to
figure out what's going on and then
we'll change it to an h2 and then here
we're just gonna grab let's see we're
gonna put in our content oops let me
copy this and paste it here there we are
oh we have alright we can't use this
exactly like music because we have our
query okay so we just need to change
where we're where we have this then so
we've used the the newer way of doing a
query so we need to switch this up a bit
so if we put it down here now we have
access to this data so you see whereas
before I had that little red squiggly
line because this didn't exist
now we don't alright so now that
constant is gonna live here within our
query and then we can change it and just
use content here all right so let's save
see what happens let's see okay cool so
look we have all this content goodness
yeah we definitely want there needs to
be some styling happening here so I
definitely want to see I'm assuming all
this was all within title tags and now
it's all h2s
yes so that's an H - that's an H - okay
we're gonna get a little creative here
with without we style this this is
definitely going to be something that
you don't normally have to do and I
don't think I started now I did not
start my timer let's see oh okay yeah
it's definitely time for me to take a
break and go back to the live chat so
I'm going to do that now
when we come back from our five minute
break then we're gonna get in here and
we're gonna style all these h2s
so that they in fact do not look like
h2s but instead look like a nice list so
really these should probably be like a
lies it should be h2 h3
el eyes we're not gonna get that right
now at some point we'll have it but not
right now all right so there's one
question at the bottom that I'm just
gonna address right now because it's
very relevant so John Hanson says for
future content that will live on the
WordPress database will users who input
new data get a set template that will
keep all things consistent with the data
pool yes yes definitely
so when possible it will be very
specific there will be certain fields
that will only allow you to input
certain types of data when we need more
of a like a Content area that can accept
HTML that will be allowed but there's
not not every user will have access to
do things like that and I will put in
instructions so usually what I do when I
make something like this and they're
going to be users that are entering
content on their own is I create some
tutorial videos for them so I'll have
either a video or a document or usually
both that outlines here's what you do
you know for all these different post
types and then within the post types
themselves I'll have instructions so
that when they go to enter something
into a field there'll be instructions
right there below it saying here's an
example of what I want so so far that's
worked well I haven't with the other
sites I've done like this I it's going
well so for this case I'll actually have
more direct contact with the people
editing it because my boss will be the
primary person editing it and then the
other developer who works right next to
me will be doing it and then student
workers that will be working right
outside my door so if there's any issues
someone could actually you know talk to
me face-to-face about it but it's I'm
definitely going to be very specific
with the instructions so they'll be
freedom to do different things where
there needs to be but it'll basically be
you know the fields will only accept
what I want them to accept at some point
and that'll probably all happen after
the launch because all that stuff's like
behind the scenes stuff that I can do
whenever and the the user you know the
ultimate user trying to look at this
site may not even realize that a change
has occurred all right so let me scroll
up and find some questions
John Hanson says looks like the dog
image has been improved using background
size cover though I think it also needs
background position Center Center
yeah it could could be I I'm not I don't
usually bother doing anything with the
stock images I kind of want to see what
images I need to use for real but John
also says add a closing X in the corner
of the menu
yeah I've I noticed this yesterday and I
think that would be a great idea that'll
probably go on the list of it's not
essential to have before we launch
because like the odds of somebody having
a phone this narrow are pretty small I
can actually look at the analytics right
now and see if anybody's using a phone
that small but that's pretty narrow and
it would be nice to have the X we can
also make this a little bit smaller I
mean really there's no reason right now
but this has to be this wide but anyway
I totally agree John I had the same
thought
brooke says isn't the menu itself
swipeable on most material design apps
yeah it usually is swipeable I don't I
was not able to swipe this but it could
be because I'm not actually on a device
alright now that I think about that I
should check this since we have n grok
running let me let me just grab the end
Rock link and I'm not going to try to
type it out I'm gonna send it to myself
let's see it's the easiest way to
centers I'll just put it my Google keep
all right so Google keep is a
note-taking app and it syncs up pretty
quickly so hopefully it syncs
immediately now and I can just open this
up on my phone because if it's if it is
swipeable then that's good to know I
still like the idea of having an icon
there just to be sure that it's you know
hundred percent clear to users but users
may also if they're used to being able
to swipe in they can't swipe that's
going to be an annoyance to them it's
not swipeable right now so when we've
done things with materialized CSS that
is swipeable but right now this is not
swipeable also that doesn't look it's
much more noticeable that there's not
enough padding at the top on mobile
right here so I definitely need to make
sure you get some padding but that's the
type of thing that I'm going to be doing
in the streams for at least today and
tomorrow is really working on some of
those little details especially on the
home page yeah we'll have to check maybe
there's an issue with material I already
open about being swipeable if not you
know maybe that's something that we can
create and maybe submit a pull request
for material UI to do that I mean that
that seems like a pretty common design
pattern for material design apps that
should be there so Niki thanks that was
a yeah Niki thanks for bringing that up
all right I need I need to take my
sweater off because it's super hot in my
office now
my office the rest of the department is
actually pretty like cold the right
outside my door is really cold the girl
who works she kind of has like an open
office thing going on but the girl who
works right outside my door always has a
blanket because it's so cold but my
office is always really warm and it's
all the screens all the screens create a
lot of heat so a sweater is appropriate
for everywhere else except through my
office
I don't want to run the fan because you
know it would mess up the audio as soon
as it streamed over I'm definitely
running the fan though alright
hey in this here hey and how's it going
and this will be the last question and
then I'll go back to the code because my
timer did run out but in it says how is
your working day not too bad today
I had a meeting so every Thursday
morning we have a department meeting and
basically everybody in my department
which is about I don't know about a
dozen people sometimes not everyone is
there but about a dozen people and we
just quickly go over what we're working
on sometimes it can get a little bit
long so I'm not I'm not a big fan of the
weekly meeting
I always keep mine short so today mine
was most of what I said was just I've
been working on this site so that was my
day but I did get some more data
transferred over which was nice I was
actually up at like 10:00 till 4:00 this
morning
and I I couldn't go back to sleep so I
just got up got a good workout in made a
latte
I ate a bunch of eggs for breakfast and
still managed to get my kids ready and
get them to school on time and get
myself into work so so not not a bad day
although right now I already feel tired
in a couple hours I'll be ready to go to
bed cuz I've been up since before 4:00
but anyway thank you for asking
and and I know it's it's on the live
chat so I usually don't ask you how
things are going but I will now so how's
everything going with you you don't have
to say in a live chat if you don't want
if you grab their answer on insta or
Twitter or something let me know but I
feel bad you're always very considerate
and asking how I am and I usually don't
during the live chat ask ask you so
anyway if you feel like sharing please
let me know
let's see alright
a related follow-up question there is
sim sim Ranjit says how is your
work-life balance and sim Ranjit if I
messed up the pronunciation of your name
please let me know I really want to get
it right right now my work-life balance
I think is pretty good I went on home
I've been doing very little work
sometimes I was still like message about
projects and things but I try not to
actually do any coding at home right now
and just spend time with my kids so it's
like it's been not bad I've been reading
to the kids and oh cool I got cimarron
G's name right awesome so I've been
spending time you know read to the kids
and hold the baby a lot and I've been
playing we got a Nintendo switch for
Christmas so I'll play that with the
kids and we it's fun because we talked
about it you know you know we'll say
like hey you know I got this today on
this game and and that's kind of fun to
have like a common interest you know
with the kids so so that's cool and I've
been getting my workouts in so this is
two weeks on Monday so over two weeks
now that I worked out every morning so I
started out in some I've been doing
cardio and now I started adding some
some weights and things so it's not bad
I actually gained like five pounds since
I started working out normally you work
out you want to lose weight but I I
assume I'm gaining muscle because I'm
working out and I'm actually eating
slightly healthier than I normally do so
anyway I think my balance is going well
right now hopefully I can keep it up and
the key for me I think the key change
that I've made is I'm going to bed early
and consistently so I rarely stay up
past like 9:30
sometimes I'm in bed before 9:00
basically when I put my kids to sleep I
go to sleep too when they're brushing
their teeth or tonight I'm brushing my
teeth and
we all you know just go to bed so that's
it I've had to sacrifice some Netflix
but I think it's worth it anyway so I
took a really long time to answer that
but I think questions like that are
important because being a developer and
being successful isn't just about the
code if you are great at the code but
you can't keep that balance you get all
stressed out you know your mental health
isn't good ever your physical health
isn't good then the code is gonna suffer
so that can be just as important as you
know you have somebody that's mentally
and physically healthy who's not that
good a developer right now then they
have a good base to learn more but if
you have somebody who's an expert but
they're their life otherwise it's a mess
you know I if I was gonna hire somebody
I'd hire the the new person that at
least has the rest of their stuff
together not that I don't have concern
for the other person I'd you know I'd
want to help them out but if I had to
choose you know for the good of a
company or something that's who I'd pick
so anyway I do want to make sure I have
content that you are interested in so if
you'd rather hear less or more about the
the other part of a developer's life the
you know physical social you know mental
let me know I can talk about that more
I'll try to make sure that I save that
for the end though because there are
some people that really just want the
code and I know they probably get
annoyed by these long breaks in the
middle of all right now I don't want to
make it sound like I always have
everything together right I don't this
just the last two weeks have been
exceptional usually like for the LAT for
months and months before that I just
felt like I didn't have anything
together and I'm sure if you asked my
wife I would sound even less together
than I sound right now this she sees
everything from a whole different
perspective so she'd probably tell you
about how I bought candy a junk food for
all the kids two days ago
and and that kind of thing but alright
let's get back to the code I'm gonna set
my timer now then I'm gonna remember to
bring it over here on this screen so we
all can see 25 minutes we're gonna do
our best to make this page look good and
then check out a few other pages just to
make sure we haven't like mess things up
on those other pages and then we'll see
how we're doing on time you know if we
get it looking good maybe we'll just you
know go back do some more question and
answer and finish up the stream we'll
see how it goes so if you do have a
question or comment or anything you know
put it in here now and then you know I
will get to it in about 25 minutes
alright so for now this h2 is fun I
usually like things to be a bit thinner
than this but I'm not gonna worry about
detail like small details right now but
this this heading definitely needs to be
smaller so let's inspect that and that's
gonna be at ABS h2 so let's go back to
our CSS file to be working mainly in
this file at this point and I don't
think we have anything with tabs yet and
let's see what we kind of wonder if we
really need this on these pages name
phone email CV link video image
blockless for details right home logs
hmm I I want to see if we're
accidentally hiding anything so I'm
gonna comment that out right now all
right it doesn't look like we're hiding
anything else so that's that's good I
just want to see what we're hiding if
we're hiding anything so let's do what
was it tabs yeah tabs and then we're
gonna do h2 right so in in CSS land
why am i all abilities empty this is how
we select an h2 that is a child of tabs
and is this is this direct child I
believe it's the direct child of tab so
that we do want to use that we can take
advantage of the cascading nature CSS
here to make sure that those sub h2s
that we're gonna get to in a minute
actually are getting the correct styles
so it won't really matter one way or
another but let's let's try this let's
try pixel oops font size and let's give
it 24 pixels
oops 24 pixels for now that may be too
big we'll see and then our font weight
let's go with 400 for now and I'm not
worried about colors so much we may get
to that but let me see what the color is
now I don't want it to be solid black so
as long as it's not solid black I'm okay
with it
where is h2 computed
huh that's interesting I wonder maybe if
there's no color set at all and this
then is the default for the browser
that's interesting
all right so what I would want is color
let's go yes so this this does look like
it is black it it matches all these so
what I really want though is to do it
like this and have 87 so I'd rather have
the color be 87 let's make sure
okay t7 it's really hard to who uh to
see a difference but that's something
that I want to apply across the board
I'm not going to worry about it right
now but let's see tabs h2 you know what
what we just did should have applied
let's make sure I'm in the right file
page so CSS why did it not apply with
what's going on tabs h2
let me see I'm gonna check the live chat
and maybe I made something different
maybe I messed something up I mean soy
su I would paramount
uh-huh this is interesting so so does
the space actually matter I was under
the impression that this the space
didn't matter but let's let's try it out
and see so the first way I did it didn't
have any effect at all now let's see
let's try again maybe I was mistaken I
think you all are right the space
mattered very interesting for some
reason I just didn't think the space
mattered I just thought that was
commonly how you wrote it
all right cool very good to know so in
case you didn't catch that originally I
had written this tabs and then you know
the this little was that a greater than
sign yeah a little greater than sign and
then h2 but I had spaces between that
but that was not the correct way to do
that so all right cool so that works
let's see how it looks
all right I'm I like that yeah I like
that I think that's it's not bad I do
want to see what the font size for this
is 24 and I don't want them to be the
same so let's drop that down then let's
drop this one down to my don't we say 20
let's try 20 see how that looks alright
um I still I don't really like that but
I'll I'll go with that for now
maybe once we drop these down in size
it'll it'll look more reasonable all
right also thanks to everyone that
pointed out that that space matters I
see several of you were we're talking
about the spaces on Hill and Nikki and
I'm not sure who else all were saying
that but everybody who was thank you all
right so let's check this
now and first we'll test out some styles
here and see see how we like it see if
we can get mmm
no it's not exactly what I want h to
title alright let's go with left and put
that there
type that up to 22 and then we're also
gonna have a right H to title alright
we'll give it a quick refresh just to
make sure okay that's a little bit more
obvious the hierarchy that we have here
and let me give it a scroll just to see
what else we have going on here all
right so we have another header it says
fall only spring only okay now obviously
we have a problem with spacing right so
let's let's deal with our spacing issues
why do we have spacing issues like this
is that these these be ours
there we go oh yeah we're gonna have to
set the BR display:none I really I hate
to do that because there may be very
meaningful you know break tags that are
in here but it just it seems like from
what I've seen of the content the break
tags are not meaningful so I think we're
better off displaying none on the break
tags and then when we need to we'll add
in padding with our CSS that's the way I
prefer anyway yeah all right so this is
looking a lot better not a hundred
percent what I would want this there's
still some some spacing issues but so
much better so let's make sure we do a
br nun which I think we already had down
here did we we did so we already had
that be our nun so I still want to leave
this commented out for now because I'd
like to know if we're hiding anything
else but I'm gonna add that BR now
so the BR set to none won't actually
hide any content anyway it'll just get
rid of space so I'm okay with having
that as display:none all right all right
so sometimes I get a red line and I
think is just delayed that it shouldn't
be there anymore it just hasn't left yet
all right just double-check make sure it
works yep that works and
what do you think you know what this is
probably throwing me off that I haven't
zoomed in alright that's that definitely
looks more reasonable I think what we
ought to do though is make sure that
there's a bit more space so let's see
what we have going on here in each tab I
think each tab should have some padding
or some margin at the bottom bottom and
let's make it 16 pixels okay let's see
what's going on it's basically done
nothing
there we are okay
okay let's throw this in here as well
all right our CSS definitely could use
some better organization but I'm always
I'm okay with letting that go until we
get farther along sometimes if you
organize prematurely then you need to
just reorganize everything again so I'd
rather not rather kind of wait till we
get more out there all right
I I don't love this this right now I
think I think that there's still not
enough distinction between these
headings and the actual content so I
either need to make this font size
smaller which I don't really want to do
I think 18 pixels is kind of the minimum
I'd like to go here so the alternative
would be to make this h2 larger and then
I can make these ones larger as well so
maybe I'll do that I'm just not sure I
don't want to think about that let's see
if you want to see how I'm on time okay
so about 10 minutes left
all right maybe let's let's try it then
we can just try it here dev tools and
see see what we want to do for 1.5 um so
what's the computed all right 24 I'm
sorry I knew that already I don't know I
forgot all right so let's try this font
size 26 pixels let's try 28 all right 28
pixels and then we can make these
24 let's see if that is enough for me
yeah I think that's that's a lot more
significant that stands out the only
other thing that I think might work as
well is let's try out let's try our font
weight here we can try 300 I like that
I really like that what do you all think
about this these changes here I still
don't like this bold being this being
that bold but I really like the thin
font let's see what the font size or
font weight is here 700 Wow no wonder
that so thick I yeah 500 is way more
reasonable yeah I usually never go above
500 for font weight okay all right so
let's change this then and so our h2s
are gonna be CSS is so messed up it is
bothering me but I'm gonna I'm gonna
hold back the urge to change it and
right now font size and font weights and
then we changed our font size here to 24
and we changed our font weight here to
300 and let's refresh just to be sure
excellent all right now it is much more
obvious with the hierarchy of this pages
alright
cool I'm really glad that I didn't just
leave that alone sometimes not being
satisfied with your design is is not the
right way to go because you spend too
much time on it but in this case this
this worked out so I don't know I think
that's kind of thing is sometimes if if
you work on something enough you start
to get a feel for something like this
isn't a big deal don't waste your time
on it or this is a big deal and you
don't always you know you don't always
choose the right thing all the time but
in this case it didn't take that long
and I think the result is a lot better
than what we had just a few minutes ago
you check my time are at six minutes
alright so now that we have this I think
we ought to check out what's going on
now with some of the other pieces of
content so I'm just gonna go back
through here the some of what we had and
scroll all right this one doesn't seem
to have any area here's some some
headings let's see what these are these
HT - yeah these are h2s okay not bad I'm
actually okay with the way this look I
think those are fun and what's this this
might not even be a H tag at all in h4
okay all right okay that's not too bad
all right so it looks like we the
hierarchy is there the hierarchy works I
oh that's way too small notice that in H
five all right so I'm definitely gonna
have to take a look at the the H tags
overall kind of the global settings for
the H tags and then change them based on
what our base font weight is which our
base font weight should be at the
minimum 16 all right so we do have 18
I'm okay with that actually like 18 B in
the base so if 18 is our base font
weight or I'm sorry font size then the
h5 s can't be
right now can't be 13.2 eight pixels so
we they have to be at least you know 20
right does that make sense that you know
any heading no matter H five or whatever
it still needs to be bigger than the
base want okay
let me check the check because I think I
asked you all what you thought about
that and I didn't even check for the
answer I apologize
Joan Anson says looks good for the fun
weights now and it says I think
display:none is a bad idea and I'd like
to know why what what's your reasoning
for thinking it's a bad idea would it be
better to just remove those BR tags
because I'm open to doing that as well I
mean the easiest way to do it is with
CSS but the easiest ways of course not
always the best way so I would I would
like to know the the thoughts behind
that okay all right if you have asked a
question I haven't got to it yet just
about four more minutes and I'll get to
all the questions so please be patient
what are these they're lies okay so it
looks like the Allies have a different
font weight but these ones don't
what are these so it our ordered lists
have a different different styles than
our unordered list so I'll probably want
to change that at some point I don't
think I'm going to try to get into it
right now because we don't have that
much time but and I just want to check
some of these other ones as well let's
see alright here's our about page so we
have this this ought to be an h2o and h1
okay I'm gonna have to make a decision
and see like what do we do we want to
have some consistency with these so I
think there ought to be if possible but
other than that I like out of this shows
up right now yeah that page is good this
associate page I think that what's wrong
with this page do we not have a title at
all huh
I may have to check out this page on the
on the site right now
and see if there's a title because that
looks odd
it's h3 at the top
yeah I think we definitely want to make
sure that all pages have a title and I'm
you know this obviously this is a
subtitle so I just need to make sure it
looks like the title doesn't exist in
the main data so maybe I will just pull
in it's different for different pieces
of content so it's it's going to be a
little tricky because sometimes in the
main content there's it already includes
the title and sometimes it doesn't so I
don't want to get duplicate titles so I
can't just add a title in across the
board like pull win the word press post
title so yeah I'm gonna have to think
about I'm gonna have to figure out which
post types are pulling in titles
automatically and which ones are and
then go from there okay
only have about a minute left I think
we've checked enough pages now I've got
h2 h3 okay not too bad all right not bad
this is all these are all acceptable I
wouldn't say that it's exactly how I
would do it if I was doing this all from
scratch and had complete freedom over
how this displays but considering that
we put in all this HTML from this old
system that had been put in by you know
a variety of different people over years
by I think it's displaying you know
quite well so or at least well enough
that I'm comfortable with something that
looks like this you know being what we
launched with
okay all right Anna just explained so
she's saying if I want to use BR in
articles I cannot because you hit it
globally that's a good point you know
that's a good point I just all right now
let's think about that we need some way
to get rid of all that space that's
coming with those those BR tags but at
the same time do we want to give the
editors the freedom to add in their own
tags and and have that be respected
I'm gonna have to think about that I
just I've I thought up a few potential
solutions but I don't think any of them
are really that good I'm thinking like
potentially we could still hide our the
BR tags and then just have a note in the
editor to let users know if you want to
use a break then use this other tag and
basically we'll just invent another tag
and make it act like a br so I don't
like that because like now users have to
remember to use another tag it's
problematic if you're copying and
pasting code from somewhere else and
trying to use that so that's why I don't
like that solution although it would
work it's not great the other solution
is to try to go through all the data
right now and remove most of the BR tags
then we don't have to hide them but that
solution would either I maybe there's a
way to do it in WordPress and alter the
database you know with one command I
don't know how to do that I could maybe
I could learn then there's a possibility
though of us my I guess we wouldn't be
getting rid of er tags where we need
them because right now we're hiding them
so it's the same thing
it could have somebody manually go
through which is going to take a while
we probably won't get that done before
launch cuz I don't really have anybody
right now but I know I could give that
task to or I can re migrate the data and
at the same time strip out the BR tags
which I really don't want to do all
right so those are my who is that for
maybe solutions I'm gonna have to think
on this a little bit more the other
solution is just to leave them hidden
for now and then have that on the list
of things for somebody to manually do
when they go through the data and then
whenever they get finished with that I
can then remove the CSS rule that hides
the BR tags and so then they'll be okay
to you
again that that actually might be the
best solution because there won't be I
don't think there will be that many
changes you know that quickly to the
site and hopefully I can get somebody to
go through that data soon let me know
what you all think I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent sure about any of them
any of those those options all right let
me scroll up a bit and answer some more
questions that'll be it for the coding
part of this so if you don't want to
stick around for the question and answer
thank you so much for watching but if
you do have a little bit more time and
you can stick around I definitely
appreciate it if you would and help
answer some questions and you know ask
some of your own if if you'd like
Aaron Arun Monterey our UN let me know
that pronounce that says says hey oh hey
how's it going thanks for for watching
okay there's a little conversation going
on here between Nikki and and on how
about CSS so I think it would be
worthwhile for me to put this in the
video for those year watching later so
let me just type a little bit in here so
the question is what's the difference
between this tabs h2 and tabs h2 so and
this one on hell is explaining this in
here so I'm not gonna read it out word
for word I'll just kind of demonstrate
here this first one only selects the
tabs that are a direct descendant of the
h2 right so there's you don't go down
any more levels it would have to be tabs
and then right after that h2s so even if
there's like five h2s as long as they're
just a child a direct child all those
eight shoes will be selected but tabs h2
will select children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren all the way down so
you could have tabs and then a div and
then within that div in h2 it will still
be selected so with the first one it
wouldn't be selected if it was inside a
div the second one it would and it could
be inside 50 dense or nested and it
would still be selected all right
hopefully that makes sense to you all
let me know if it doesn't but there's
our CSS lesson of the day
brought to you by own hell thank you
very much
grim reaper says why is it said that
front-end web development is pretty
messed up I don't I don't know I think
people here's my guess I obviously don't
know what the intentions are of the
people who say this but based on what
I've seen of people saying that and
similar things my guess is that there is
so there are so many different options
and there's not there's usually not one
clear front-runner for how to do pretty
much anything in front-end you know from
you know what UI framework am I going to
use to MIT you SAS les post CSS styled
components glamour you know it there's
so many options you know what routing am
I going to use for reacts what am I
going to use to manage you know data how
what am I gonna have for a back-end you
know it's just there's so many options
now and so many good options that it can
be confusing to someone maybe they're
coming from a different area of
programming where there are clear
frontrunners you know it's more like
okay everybody does it this way they
come here and it's like the Wild West of
programming where you know anybody can
just open up a git repo with a new way
to style react components and they've
put it on Twitter it gets a bunch of
retweets and now a week later that's a
legitimate way to do it and you have you
know good really good developers all of
a sudden using it saying it's awesome so
I can see that as being pretty confusing
you know it ever even your build tools
are we gonna use grunt the web pack
would there's there's just so many
options for everything the only thing
that seems pretty standard in front-end
world is almost everybody uses get right
get is standard so other than that it's
just you know everything is is just up
for grabs I personally like that I love
that there's so many options because
it's not boring every project we do we
try
something new that's really cool so
we're always learning so we get better
with the stuff that we've kept them on
in the project but then now we've added
this other thing in so we're always
having to learn new things I like that
about it and you know what front end
it's just things developed so rapidly I
don't know I think that's that's cool
Harshit mentioned get is used by
everyone else too yeah I didn't mean to
imply that gets only in the front end
I'm just saying that's an example of
something that is consistent among
front-end developers is that they do use
get I have seen like it in where I work
the IT department doesn't use get they
use something different I can't I can't
remember what these fault
I think it's fault they use visual
sourcesafe for a while and they switch
the vault yeah so I mean that but
basically the point is that I could see
why people would think it is a mess but
once you get an idea of I don't know
once you start to learn more about it
and you can kind of visualize where
everything falls into place and where
the options are you know what the
options are like I think it makes a lot
more sense so at first it's definitely
confusing like what do I learn how does
it all fit together like you know just
figuring out what everything is for is
is a big step right they the names don't
always say what these things are for or
what they do anyway that's that's kind
of my viewpoint on it but as I said I I
really don't know what the intentions
are beyond you know everyone that says
that
I lost my place in the lab chats I'm
scrolling through now trying to find
where I was
Bhupinder says which software are you
using to share screen or record the
screen it's called OBS so it's free and
it's available for Mac and I believe
Windows as well I haven't tried to use
it on Linux I think it's available for
Linux but some of you people use Linux
let me know if it's available for Linux
as well I don't want to mislead anyone
but it takes a little while to get used
to the settings and to get them just
right but once you get the settings down
it's it's really easy to use I recommend
just finding someone else who hasn't set
up properly and trying to get their
settings and just copy it and then you
can adjust them based on what you need
but that's what I did I went out and
watched videos from from gamers who were
doing live streams and just kind of
tried to figure out okay what do I need
from there and adjusted it so like I
don't really need 60 frames per second
for what I do so that's something I can
back down on whereas gamers generally
prefer that so just kind of adapt it to
your needs if you're interested in using
it
origin says what's the best way to
integrate react with an external API it
depends on so alright it depends on a
couple of things like if you're trying
to grab data from an external API and
you want it to be server-side rendered
then I would use something like next
that handles a lot of that for you
and then you can use what's built in
from next to be able to grab that data
and render server-side if that really
doesn't matter I would just use fetch
you could fetch client-side or
server-side whatever you want so there's
a node fetch that you can use as well
but yeah just use the fetch API and I
think that's that works well for for me
someone mentions harsh mentions Axios
yeah you people have used Axios as well
I personally don't use Axios but a lot
of people like it so I can't really
explain why you would want to use it
because I don't I haven't used it but
that's another option instead of fetch
that's another area where it's like the
question was what's the best way and we
automatically have two really good ways
to do it
that's like what's the best way I don't
know but I'm sure we could debate and
then somebody else will throw in by the
time we're done with the debate we'll
have even more options and no clear
winner so that's just the way things are
in JavaScript world right now
Aniki said thanks for the explanation I
assume it was about the CSS stuff you're
welcome no problem Gregory says I'm new
to this chat where did you get the
Pomodoro timer
Harshit made the Pomodoro timer so harsh
it mentioned that in the lab chat yeah
but our should actually made it so yeah
it's let me get the URL for you it's pom
pom now SH that's P om p om pom pom now
SH and I will copy and paste that into
the live chat so you can click I want to
make sure I read it out as well for
those who are gonna be watching later
who or who can't access the live chat
right now John Henson says globally set
small zero margins top and bottom on all
text tags and HR it's easy to find a
sweet spot and if you have three or four
media queries you can change these
margins using e/m is helpful to its
dynamic okay just think about that so
yeah I mean I think there's definitely a
lot more testing and work to be done CSS
wise to make sure this all this all
looks alright but as I said a lot of
what we're bringing in now is acceptable
not exactly where I want it but I can't
I can't start to perfect this until I
make sure I have all the data the number
one thing now is is there readable data
here for every page and have I kept the
URLs intact as much as possible that's
number one priority after that if that's
finished then I can start to get into
things like you know it business look
exactly how I want it to look or you
know whatever else we want to want to
work on
harsh asks is there anything that you
use to design sites like overall color
scheme and other typography and stuff I
use material design for almost all of my
sites some side projects I do like I
just experiment with different things
but for my professional projects I
usually stick with material design the
color schemes so I work for University
the color schemes that I use for the
University all come from the official
palette which was developed by one of my
colleagues here at where I work so I'm
kind of bound to that now the way I use
those colors and the amounts you know
that's up to me so I've had some trial
and error with that but to get to the
point where we have this this color
scheme that we're using right now like
this you know that that was essentially
just trial and error and seeing what
looks good what doesn't look good and
starting to get a feel for like what
colors can go up against each other and
look okay and which ones can't alright
so like you the green color actually
doesn't look good right up against a
white background so it's always bordered
by the gold which you can see in the
footer here even a tiny Goldwater makes
a huge difference so as you start to
work with a color palette you do get a
feel for it but then just for a lot of
different things like the shadow
you know menu styles and things icons I
pull a lot from the material design
philosophy so even like the way the way
inputs behave you know Google's put a
lot of time and money and there are a
lot of very experienced talented people
that have developed material design so I
can't compare with that so I'm going to
use that it provides a very familiar
user experience so I love the idea that
a user can come to my site and
immediately feel comfortable with the
navigate
and the visual hierarchy of things you
know based on like the perceived depth
of elements on the page with the shadows
so I'd like to use that for my side
projects sometimes I like to be pretty
experimental like I like to give a retro
look to things and I kind of mess with
like dark color themes a lot as well so
I'm a little bit more playful and
creative when it comes to that but if I
happen to have a client on the side
usually like when it comes to colors I
am also bound by whatever their branding
is most companies already have that so
you work with what you have there
usually if a client has it one or two
colors that are just really ugly you you
just use them as sparingly as possible
so I prefer the use of white a lot when
I'm dealing with things like that so I
personally I love dark themes but I just
I don't know they don't always work and
clients usually don't like them that
much like sometimes I've had clients ask
for a darker theme but then once they
see it next to the white theme they they
don't like it I don't know what that I
don't know why it's not every client but
there's just for some reason you know
people seem to like the the white
all right I think I've gotten through
all the questions now so cool all right
innocence I like the design of the site
thanks Anna I appreciate that that's
that's one of the things that it's
always difficult I think to work with
design people by that I mean that
clients and things always have a lot of
opinions about what they like I think at
the end of the day the thing to keep in
mind is the client the user right not
not not the client but the you the end
user so your clients clients right
that's who you want to think about and
for me
usability always takes a higher place
than just style alone sometimes I get
ideas from clients that are really cool
that stylistically would look awesome
but then if you say all right well how's
it gonna look on a phone how's it gonna
look on a tablet what if you put it in
landscape you know there's these these
things that you know sometimes people
don't always think of so sometimes you
have to sacrifice that creative style
for usability and I think material
design does that that's why I like it so
much if it depends on what kind of site
if let's say I was doing a personal site
just to showcase my work or my portfolio
I could probably get away with being a
lot more creative and not worry so much
about user experience but it's just you
got to balance that so I don't think my
sites
most of my sites I wouldn't call
beautiful I would maybe just got
describe them more as like clean
minimalist right they're just I try to
focus them make them to the point make
him easy to use
I don't know I think there's beauty in
that to see heart says okay thanks for
the info I will look into material
design I've never worked with it before
yeah check it out the docks are very
comprehensive so if you go to like the
official Google material design Docs you
know just read through some of their
philosophy and click around and just
look at their examples I really like the
way that they they set up their their
documentation harshest but sometimes you
do see sites that have both creativity
animations and responsive at the same
time I get so jealous of such developers
yeah you do yeah so it's always going to
be a balance between creativity and
usability but some people manage to
strike that and it's the result is
pretty amazing so it just takes a lot of
work right so you go with something
that's pretty standard like material
design you can make sites faster if you
want to do something that has a lot of
creativity animation and stuff and still
made it works on your different devices
and is usable it takes a lot of time a
lot of testing I can be confident that a
lot of material design stuff will work
on different devices because others have
tested if I'm coming up with my own
thing that all falls on me the odds of
there being some glitches are a lot
higher but anyway right now it just so
happens that I don't really have the the
freedom to do things super creative you
know and I'm okay with that I have a lot
of freedom and with the tools that I use
so I'm happy with that
but I don't know maybe one day I'll get
more creative with the you know design
side of things and we'll see I like
where I'm at right now I like what I'm
doing all right so that's that's it
that's so add all this stuff in the live
chat right now so I'm gonna end this
dream now
thank you all so much for watching
really appreciate all the help or the
comments questions y'all are awesome so
I will be back tomorrow and this would
be good if everything goes well tomorrow
this will be a whole week of streams
consistently around the same time so
it's been a while since that's happened
but anyway until tomorrow have a great
day